hello I am welcome to the show this is
mark Normand a Jim Norton hit on hello
I'm Sam Roberts
Samiha yes pleasure I be obviously
promoting a Unabomber series series yeah
I guess you did a lot of research into
these kind of a fascinating guy yeah
well it was I played a guy that actually
kind of go that catching I play they got
it when to catch him so I did a lot of
research into him as opposed to Paul
Bettany plays the Unabomber so he took
that side and it's about how these two
guys kind of clash not only in one guy
trying to catch the other guy before he
kills more people but also just in how
they emotionally affect each other
what did CBS or something one of the
news stations had a weird deal with the
FBI when that actually really happened
where they got exclusive coverage
because they were there early they
showed up before any other news people
before he was even busted and they knew
something was wrong so a few things
happen remember the movie inside to a
bar to die structure to a bar in the
area they knew they were close where the
Unabomber eventually was found in that
area we remember the insider with Al
Pacino I do remember I myself I don't
know Pacino plays that guy Tom actually
remember his name but he was a low
Bergman was okay and he was a reporter
that had a tip-off and said to him look
you think you know where he's going to
be you've got we're going to give you 24
hours before we break the story of where
the Unabomber is and so that really
intensified the FBI having to go in and
take down this guy but by that time they
had caught him for 17 years they had no
information about where or who he was or
why he was doing what he was doing and I
show explores all of that down to that
last 24 hours where they had to get a
search warrant offer basically a thing
that was created called forensic
linguistics which was my character
discovered well we've got no actual
evidence to put this guy at any of the
scenes but what we do ever his own words
because the Unabomber wrote a manifesto
it was like 56 pages that he got the
Washington Post to publish up and down
that he would describe why his
reasonings for doing it and this guy the
guy play a local Jim Fitzgerald took all
those words who managed to figure out
who the hell this guy was just off words
and axioms and spelling and very nice it
was hidden someone in his family
recognized it to like his brother or
somebody
recognize like an arrogant asked like
that like if you let him just talk is
going to say something that people who
know him record I think somebody that I
think everyone believes yeah his brother
turned him in which in a way is true but
his brother only turned him in because
he recognized because they published the
Washington Post my characters was the
one that said to do that because he said
look someone's going to read Arling and
realize that the tone of the spelling
and the tone of the way they speak
because we all speak our own certain
ways and have their own kind of
linguistics fingerprint when we talk so
someone want to recognize that but to
actually publish you something except
some madman that bombing all these
planes and vomit all these people to
write to do that is kind of ballsy as
well yeah because that promotes other
crazies to say well we're going to block
more people to you promote our rants
what's that the word we're manifesto
came from I remember ever hearing about
a manifesto until the you know I'm sure
it exists did that's where if you kind
of went into the lexicon versus it yeah
yeah yeah yeah and I got popularized
yeah I mean you wonder I mean does that
change your perspective when you see
crimes that happen now because now I
mean is when media post pictures and
stuff of a lot of these criminals and
they do a lot of people and I kind of
side with the people who feel like you
shouldn't be posting pictures of it
because it's what they want like when
that kid shot up the movie theater and
everybody was calling him the Joker
right and look like this super villain
you know is always a way to kind of turn
it back the good about putting it out
there is that someone like oh I know
that person I know the inside track yeah
that person is acting sketchy and
therefore they did buy a trench coat and
some pipe bombs rain will stop it from
happening so that kind of thing has a
you know the sword cuts both ways back
then there was no internet you know this
is said in the 90s so the guy had been
bombing for 16 years he disappeared for
six of those so and so they had no way
of actually communicating with the
public other than through the newspaper
medium and to do that any other time
they had done it was with the Zodiac
killer and we all know how that turned
out yeah it never caught that's like
yeah so isn't it amazing the political
police work like I'm always fascinated
like when you see like a serial killer
or whatever this guy like the amount of
time they put into like the patience the
police will exhibit when they're going
after you like is it the one guy will
just spend years talking with this thing
is well-planted dude
his his way of looking at a crime was
through words that's what it was and I
thought well how are you going to make
that interesting how you going to make
it you don't rather than using really
you know specky kind of camera shots
which they didn't we didn't really want
to do but the actual taking how we write
and taking this kind of weird way of how
we spell certain words and trying to
find to match that with other letters in
itself is just intrinsically interesting
because as you said the patience it
takes to do that the way that you can
literally actually focus your attention
that much that's what I found
fascinating this there's a kind of a
same kind of thing when you're acting
you trying to take the scripts and
that's what you've really got and you
have to split this script apart to
create an actual three-dimensional
character so in the way they're doing it
but instead of profiling a character
that actually profiling people that are
bombing people but I have especially a
you watched Serpico like in 1974 that
some guy did this step to get on a book
and with a magnifying glass and start
looking up fingerprints like oh yeah I
had boxes of letters well hated wrote to
his brother and that's what happened he
went around the brothers house and by
that time the brother said look I think
this might be my brother but you don't
want to admit someone you're sure okay
so we said what I have those hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of letters
that Ted's giving me what we have emails
nowaday over the years so this guy
salivated took them all my character
took them all and analyzed and put what
was written in the manifesto connected
to the letters and see if he could find
common links and common phrases and
that's how they managed to get a search
warrant Wow and that had never been done
let's go was a real rebel a real
outsider in the sense of his way of
looking at crimes wasn't just through
get the right forensics of a fingerprint
was he was creating something on the fly
so he was against the system because
everyone thought it was crazy to say
well how could we were we using spelling
we should be getting a as you said a
hair or serrated but back then that's he
that's what he created to cachi Union
and that's enough for a search warrant I
mean it's not like you're saying that
he's the guy that did it but if a guy is
spelling one word for guys murdering
people are spelling one word
particularly came down to a phrase eat
your cake and have it too that's when
I'm dancing and we say to have your cake
and eat it right that's actually wrong
bad se3 500 years ago the
when the same came out it was to eat
your cake and over to which makes more
sense does so over the years it's got
twisted and turned around and now Ted
Kaczynski who was the Unabomber used
that phrase correctly eat your cake take
it I just made me hate him more than I
ever hated them actually is the most
offensive thing he used it in a letter
and used it in the manifesto every day I
circled and I kept coming back to this
one phrase saying that this is the comp
the common commonality of this phrase it
can't it can't be anyway it's a great
hint yeah that pomposity is what did a
miss yeah yeah yeah there's a real
arrogance to say here's 56 pages you
were printed or I'm going to blow people
up yeah because what I have to say is
more important than you and yeah there
is stuff in the manifesto that to be
honest I do agree with I don't agree
with how he did it
attorney grew with blowing people up to
get his words out there but there is
stuff in that manifesto that we created
all this technology and now the
technology would come and take us over
look at this real connected the damn
phone oh yeah that's meant to be
connectivity but we're less connected
when we're on our phones if you're in a
room with a bunch of people so he had
predicted that in the 90s yeah and
that's what his thing was that we got to
get back to nature
the problem was he didn't feel he's
being heard so his arrogance was I'm
going to write about it and blow people
up so you listen you know the technology
Frazee people are such a hatred to
technology and they're right it does
sometimes make us a little bit more
distant but people forget like what
horrible people we were before
technology you know slavery world war
one world war two all that stuff
happened before detecting more I think
his concern was or that will coming
slaves to the systems that we create
yeah I right that would be slaves to us
yeah there's a motif in the the show
about stopping at a red light we get
these cars but the red lights going to
tell us when to drive it
no yeah granted if it wasn't it'd be
chaos on the streets but that was
there's the idea we start to create
these computers and technologies in a
way turn back and impinge our freedom
and you forget that your true like a
person forgets that they're choosing to
stop at a red light like you don't have
to stop at a red light thank you you're
gonna Schmitz there's laws and
everything but the Caunt you're
inaccurate person in a car like you
don't have to stop at around that was
convinced keys concerns that our
freedoms and our autonomy of freedom of
thought is being taken away
yeah it's it's you know the same against
a double-edged sword
yeah right avoids the traffic the way I
Drive really terrible
right yeah have you gone through every
Red Alert but it's and it is funny
though that you can go through something
like that like that's have a manifesto
and you're like yep yeah yeah okay no no
no no you can't be blowing up PBS yeah
yeah you're like yeah yeah you get to
the end you're like no and throw it out
and I says it was the fact that he
wanted to be heard so much that he's
willing to kill people to make people
pay attention you know we have that
nowadays with any kind of terrorist they
kind of put themselves on YouTube and so
if you don't do what we want we're going
to cut this guy's head off it's horrific
and that's what the Unabomber was you
know we've got a for all the the
coolness of this the one photo of him in
sunglasses yes yes he was a terrorist
that's what he was yeah and it's also
that a lot of is personal megalomania
and personal arrogance that people have
it's like they're not always just doing
unpopular things for the greater good a
lot of just self-centered selfish awful
deep nature did you come to admire
anything about those I'm just thinking
what he's talking about
renovated was weird because you're
playing a guy that read the manifesto
hundreds of times so I read it as much
as I could and by doing that you
intrinsically get linked to the
Unabomber because you're reading his
writings as I said this stuff in the
manifesto I understand the middle I
don't agree absolutely
but with my character it was a sense of
I don't think he actually revered the
Unabomber because he wanted to catch him
he's a bad guy but I think he kind of
had to understand him in order to catch
it yeah on what level did you have to
start becoming I don't know but I'm sure
not an expert but you had to learn the
case yeah the case and and how one
determines all that through texting and
phrasing and that's the interesting
thing I've done a movie with Hacksaw
Ridge yeah yeah yeah and I really got a
lot out of it because you could actually
you know read in the history books
everything that happened and the
mechanics of what you're doing in the
war zone you know you could it that was
interesting to me this is same with this
the mechanics of how this guy called him
and what he had to do in ripping apart
that's interesting for me to do every
day so
that's why I like the nonfiction things
that's why I think it worked well on
Discovery because if you look at
discovery shows they're about fishing
Yukon Gold all this the mechanics of
what it takes the mined gold to catch
fish this is the mechanics of what it
takes to actually track down a unabomber
who no one has any idea who he is
thinking you also the didn't you get rid
of a lot of your possessions you sold a
lot of your stuff you got rid of stuff
and you kind of went almost bare minimum
and you were just in your car I mean so
the subject is that one part of you that
kind of understands this desire just to
get rid of everything that has made you
who you think you're supposed to be
reciclar at 30 that's exactly right
yeah got rid of everything I own to
going to turn 30 why did do it so I
looked in the mirror and I didn't like
what I saw so I thought a silver mirror
and everything else and you said it I
looked around the room defined by this
and I wasn't who I thought I wanted to
be what didn't you like what it was hey
little guy all right no man thank you
very much no is more we are defined by
our physicians in a weird way witness
one by the car we drive where you know
the clothes you wear and there was
something about it that felt a bit off I
can't put it into words if I could it
would have made more sense
well you adjusted the things some of
them yeah having on minimalism the
documentary yeah I have three amazing
yeah and you know I'm 10 years old in
there and I'm about to move and we're
packing up the house and I my argument
is now with my wife what do we need all
this garbage for it's just so much junk
that we've accumulated in the last 10
years and I said half this stuff are
going to remember getting never never
been Brett you using again and so once
again it comes back and get you
that's a nature thing no like that I
really think that they say like hoarding
is a weird like leftover DNA thing like
I save everything like by bite this is a
flyer like it's a it and you're those
guys like my mother could throw a
wedding album down I wish I that good
memories oh you do yeah yeah look I've
got my kids first haircut
stuff like that yeah but that my wife
doesn't understand that but my wife's
clothes my clothes a DVD I could get rid
of yeah that that stuff is yeah what was
the hardest thing to sell sorry no I
sell everything what was the hardest
thing that you like I got to do this to
get to this this principle that I'm
trying to achieve 30 nothing because I
stole it
you know arrogantly this sounds sell my
soul if I kept going down the same route
hmm move all you're doing we're playing
things are you not being mean or being
true to me mmm so I would have been now
in my 30s looking at myself going you're
something that has been created by the
outside being inside and the stuff right
yes amazing yes and do you mean that to
in in business mainland in acting like
you're just chasing roles to make money
as opposed to doing no acting a look at
those always look at as a job and yeah I
don't it was never you it's never been
your life it's what you do it is it is
more life though but it's a job but I
don't put it on a pedestal
gotcha I don't yeah I think you know
this fella grams is it difficult to
wrestle with this sort of like inner
minimalist that you are and also be the
star of like the biggest movie of all if
I am it monetarily my favorite is well
you got it create you go to these crazy
things right and they take they say come
into this hotel room you can have a pic
of anything you want clothes watches
just because you did a fancy movie
that's right a bunch of bunkum to me man
you won't take this out I'll take it and
give it to my mates and they don't like
that item mate I gave him a pair of
shoes I said like I wear size 12 it's
about a 10 and the lady refused to give
me the shoes and I said well I look my
feet more anxiously shrink cuz I don't
buy that I gave some to the cleaning
woman in the hotel because we were
partying back then and I thought well
you can have the jewelry that's awesome
to me that is your wife objective that
isn't like I kind of win but to me they
don't give it to you when you need it
it's like radiated a car way back as
soon as you do a movie and you can
afford a car all these idiots come out
we work and go hey do you want a new
Audi right man give it to you give it to
a struggling actor yeah get the car go
to the audition to get the job to have a
career in the life right but they just
want a photo of you in who are wearing
the shoes and who I struggle with it
right and I'm an amazing way to live now
that's a great way to live to not be
obsessed with the material stuff because
you really don't realize how like how
much you think of it or how much it
means to you until until you like you're
threatened with not having a thing like
[ __ ] I'm not gonna get this the thing
that I'm entitled to and that's human
nature you see people at concert a guy's
got a t-shirt gun and people are
fighting for the day
she'll never wear it's not your size
right I don't like what you only know
what's on and exactly each other for it
yeah but if you ever get into a free
[ __ ] room and be like I don't buy into
this I don't really want that now don't
go and you won't smart good is there
anything you might want knows I'll just
go to not like I know not if it's my
might birthday yeah oh you go yeah I'll
go with him
what makes you feel really good
obviously had family your kids but like
what what can you buy the guy like dad
this is something I just my kids that's
it give it to my kids right tell you
your will you go into a free [ __ ] room
if it's like all kids stuff all I'm a
kid going right like yeah yeah I know
now you teaching him about materials
yeah well he you know he's a kid you
know yeah he was he learned about the
forest strain in the sand oh did you
have money when you were growing up no
not really
okay we were normal family I just inches
average middle class yeah yeah okay she
didn't grow up poor and you didn't grow
up with my dad worked in a power plant
my mom cleaned houses and was a that's
what I was ordinary okay so you worked
what you had did you die really like
send you across country when you were a
kid and have you worked your way back to
17 was Christ sent me to that well I
didn't know what I wanted to do in my
life so he said well why don't you go to
the other side of the country and figure
it out
and so I got off the plane I dad gave me
what he had in his wallet like a couple
hundred bucks and then that was it
get off the plane got a job and then
let's go I think my first job was doing
the you know the pedal box rig and sure
yeah everything I had a extraordinarily
large job they did pretty quickly to
throw being a pedal bike one time here
in New York you see once for warriors I
was were the one who played Julian as
really was Julian he played book the Sun
with the half of tattoo artists he lived
in New York for I forget his real name
is Julian sorry he lived in New York for
a while and and he was driving it I was
what he was doing this driving one of
those penalties I answer once a warrior
it was crazy yeah yeah hanging out just
didn't want to come to New York and I
can hang out a little bit yeah that was
the thing that just wanted me to do
whatever I could and you do you get a
better sense of who you are and what you
want to achieve and you get a bit of
work ethic how
did you go without singing though yeah
why my way back and then I said right
now I'm going to go the other way
went the other way around didn't make
you I would be so scared to do that I
guess it makes you braver and more
self-sufficient yeah I think that's the
point right
what's dangerous anyways dangerous man
you get hit by bus crossing the street
probably wouldn't never we didn't look
at it that way yes you 17 you're
bulletproof everybody want to be away I
want to be explaining things and you
know I don't know like I would do that I
would do it to my kid we were they go go
from yeah my sister was even crazy and
my sister got to 17 and said I want to
do it Sam didn't because I got sent to a
really hot the tropical part of
Australia she thought I'll go there and
go on the beach
my mum dad sent his England with in the
middle of winter Wow good luck he did it
the hard way
now is there air B&B installer that when
she went or nah man yeah backpack is and
stuff like that so we I remember wow
that's I can't comprehend that that's
right I really admire that like I need
my comics I need my [ __ ] I need to know
where I'm going and just to be thrown
you need this trip yeah I probably don't
worry I'm not doing it but you probably
right out there sell some of them is I
don't have a lot of material things just
like stupid things that mean something
to me
but they just clogged up space they
don't do anything yeah yeah yeah humor
is a good good it's better you get the
more you memory goes into Swiss cheese
anyway so really that's dr. Sun
literally I'm just dropping out mix 10
right now sir 49 over 10 41 and my
memories not as but it don't what you
say they were weird yeah you start to
notice that you do fading with names and
then I'm like well do I just have too
much information or arms up with a rim
yeah yeah and it's just starting to
bleed out the other side or is it
worthless information is it's the phone
that's [ __ ] us up because you're
always texting you don't need to
remember anybody's numbers to remember
anything you just talk from series so
maybe I mean it's also the amount of
[ __ ] that goes on like the longer you
live the more stuff there is when you're
a kid you remember everything because
you get you know 10-15 years what was
interested reflect on if you look at the
Unabomber case they found takers in
skiing a cabin in the middle of Montana
and he'd done that he dropped off the
grid and in the cabin that we replicated
the cabin exactly as it was in our show
and there's stuff in there there was not
just a typewriter in bed there was
actual
of from books to little intrinsic things
that obviously used to build his bombs
but there was other stuff that was like
memorabilia you know memories from his
childhood photo other so creature
comfort yeah so even though a guy that
literally was off the grid completely
gone that's how they couldn't catch him
he still had these things that made him
feel comfortable
how far would he go to mail the letters
to guy no he would get into a bike get
onto a bike and he would ride heeled on
a bus he would mow a lot of San
Francisco they were taking about three
days on a bus flat and for him a letter
and would mail the letters in bulk and
that's what they couldn't understand
they were like well he must be in the
San Francisco area
but he wasn't he was in Montana so he
took a bus from Montana to down there
Oakland just look and find a model here
to keep himself what do you mean back
melanin bak malum they used to come in
there like five six at a time see that
these different letters spread out and
of course bombs would come in one week
then all with the bridges destination in
two weeks so they're going well he
wasn't mailing just one bomb they'd come
and hit hit hit okay it's like the
Tripitaka we fight like fire I got I got
a couple of these I came here actually
carrying a bomb yeah that is the sign of
a sociopath if you take a three-day bus
trip with a bomb and you know more than
once
yeah that's amazing a three-day but like
you wouldn't think he'd make it three
days right like even the first one and
this is something he did right and then
he had a fake mustaches glasses and one
of those they found all these in his in
his cabin found a dialog and a log entry
where he would log down what's disguises
he used this time you remember this guy
had an IQ 167 so he's a bona fide genius
yeah and he realized what I'm using this
disguised and someone recognized in this
disguise I better change up as disguise
and I make a log of it
so this was used against him in his
court case all this kind of smoking gun
material that they found in the cabin
yeah um was to get into the cabin they
needed something that had never been
done before which was the forensic
linguistics use of language so there's
the the crux of the show yeah in order
to get the guy to remain in jail you had
to prove that this thing that this guy
created that my character created could
actually hold weight and didn't they
have to take I believe they also took
his entire cabin
did they lift the cabin and just take it
I think they say that as evidence
because it was
but we know that in the in the show I
really had asked some radio and even
things of that iconic photograph of the
drawing the drawing isn't of him when
they he was only seen by one woman she
saw the what you know the Unabomber and
they put it with a sketch artist they
did this original sketch they say about
five six years later they got her back
together again and they got what's
called the Ike this iconic sketch the
problem was she was remembering the
sketch artist so the picture of the
sketch artists is some weird thing that
your brain does and she was remembering
remembering the Unabomber and on our
process the sketch artists that the
sketch that you see now this famous
iconic image is actually of the original
sketch artist oh my god funny that is so
I've run it realizing by the time I was
four years yeah cuz never seeing the
real photo much like he looks like a
[ __ ] hobo weirdo right on the nougaty
somehow longing yes man we yeah they
wanted that that you look like a badass
no no no the glasses are you so are you
guys shooting avatar two three four and
five all in a row yeah pretty much
so is that when does that start we
started and it enter now you're locked
into Avatar world for how long long as
Jim wants Jim Cameron but you give can
you do other stuff while you're filming
he sets up the gym right you're locked
in it's kind of weird like the first one
he told me it would take six months and
so on the third ended the six months so
she can by the hands here thanks boss
thanks to the job anyway talking about
still going cut to 15 months later Wow
we were doing the first and I think I
took time off did a terminator movie
came back did more on Avatar yeah so he
plays by his own rules
is it daunting to be like okay I know
how long it won Avatar movie to now
we're gonna do four more
you think yeah is that crazy it's crazy
it is right but it's steady work and I
love Jim like he's very rare that you
get to work with a guy of that trying to
caliber sure um I hear he's terrifying
you know he's okay temper was he really
flips out he cares
Oh ash in it yes plus we're going to
start a film you probably get yelled at
less
Rep who drive money is he different he
cares about what he but there's no one
he's not beholden to anyone so it's his
baby so we all care about that that's
what it's about and it feels I was
talking before it doesn't feel massive
it feels like this weird dysfunctional
family and it doesn't feel like you're
doing probably the biggest movie of all
time are you right now shooting too we
doin concurrent to be doing two and
three together here we're training at
the moment I gotta do all the stuff we
have to do today he wants us to do
everything did you talk to him about
James Cameron so fascinating because he
went down to that with that Marianas
Trench which is called via the lowest
point in the ocean um and I think he's
one of the only people in ever submarine
him so he did yet okay say oh but you're
so you're you're so isolated I think
he's one of the only people to ever do
it alone yeah he's the first solo he
going well he was the first fellow guys
and you're helpless if it is a
mechanical problem you dead and yeah
you're dead weight would be like a
Megalodon down there or some other that
yes no one had been down there yeah I
talk about it yeah absolutely well he
was building the submarine when we were
filming the first one so and he was
built the submarine in the deserts in
Australia the place were Albury Wodonga
which is the middle of no it's nowhere
near the ocean but he said that's where
they have the best engineers and so
that's for some of us what he's like he
goes and finds the best people in the
world because he can and he built this
submarine to help them design it and
he's extremely smart so what did he do
so you're filming avatar and he's like
okay we're going to shoot this day this
day this day I'm taking this day off to
go do some submarine work and then we're
back there now this is the mission so
when that was when he wasn't working so
when he's working he's making avatar one
then if he goes and does a solo mission
to the Mariana Trench on his time off
right um
like a mission to my husband again doing
these movies is the next mission and
that's how we look at it you come in
he's the general on the hill he's
actually not only who most generous are
on the hill most direct to sit on the
hill and bark orders he's in the trench
with you here and that's what I love
about yeah man he's done everything he's
if he could act he would it's amazing to
me that a guy with that might and we
have to wrap up very soon so just so you
know we're promoting manhunt Unabomber
premieres August 1st at 9 o'clock on
discovery it's a special two-hour
episode
to premiere and it's a fascinating case
I'm gonna watch this night I thought I
knew a lot about it but there's a lot of
obviously don't know about it so I
really want to see this because it's an
amazing insight into how they caught him
yes but what a guy like James Cameron
who has so much money he's got so much
prestige that you know Sam and I were
talking before the top two thumbs of all
time he's our his yeah and he's still
going to the bottom of the ocean by
himself no saying what does it take to
make someone feel like I don't have to
do anything what does it take to get
that dopamine drip like for me it would
be so much less but I guess you have to
keep on usually illegal but yes I will
yeah he likes the adventures he likes
the June as you said they threw me my
dad threw me to the other side of the
country no 17 SL me and Jim get along
you both kind of like the same endurance
yeah you like this journey this
exploration film gives you that
exploration who who cooks in your family
just curious you or your wife would she
ever if she presented to you a cake that
look like that would you be like oh this
looks delicious
there's everything she cooks is the best
it had a boy smart get your cake and eat
it too
how about a bit of a stranger oh yeah so
you can't eat your cake and how about it
really but tell me you didn't know
pretend you ate that cake like that's
not like at the top look delicious and
light and airy
he's the talk but see I get in there
Anthony's mom makes it we can make it
fun so fun yeah I love an abominable
call she's terrible she is horrible what
did she make it from scratch or is
inning it's her second attempt this was
her take her cake because before she
made a cake that was bad and this was
her cake to prove that she was a good
cook my birthday that was what she made
me for my birthday that's that's a heap
of [ __ ] he walks in with a fire